[Música]
con música
consignas y pancartas miles de jóvenes
de diversas partes del mundo marcharon
en la ciudad de escocesa de glasgow sede
de la cob 26 su objetivo presionar a los
líderes mundiales presentes en la
conferencia de las naciones unidas sobre
el cambio climático
porque esta es la mejor oportunidad para
que en particular los jóvenes escoceses
hagan oír sus voces a personas que
pueden marcar la diferencia
creo que muchas veces cuando pensamos
globalmente en el cambio climático
pensamos en impactos en el futuro como
un futuro distópico pero para las islas
es el presente
activista sueca greta convert líder de
estas manifestaciones juveniles dijo
presente en la concentración
no es un secreto que la cob 26 es un
fracaso debería ser obvio que no podemos
resolver una crisis utilizando los
mismos métodos que nos metieron en ellas
pero la inacción de los líderes les va
llenando de desesperanza
a mujeres
creo que hay algunos que tal vez nos
escuchen que tal vez quieran ayudarnos
pero muchos están aquí solo para mostrar
que están aquí no creo que realmente les
importe
el movimiento juvenil entregó este
viernes un documento con sus principales
exigencias piden que los jóvenes sean
incluidos en la toma de decisiones para
la creación de políticas ambientales y
que dichas políticas estén alineadas con
las guías de los científicos para
reducir el consumo de combustibles
fósiles y promover la transición
energética